so much value that is being created and
that we are just throwing away so I
think this is this is I think this is
probably the most important at the end I
we have right
new business models are going to happen
and we are not going to buy a lot of
stuff we are going to benefit from high
quality services and that's also an
aspect that I think will interest many
many people at least young people who
are not so crazy about owning things any
longer they want to share things they
want to benefit from services circular
economy is by definition more labor
intensive and we have high unemployment
in Europe today so so the jobs dimension
i think is very very important
you